and for more tonight I'm joined Now by
retired lieutenant general Ben Hodges
he's the former Commanding General of
the U.S army here in Europe it's good to
see you again this evening there's a lot
to talk about tonight I want to start
with what the Russian president didn't
say today he surprised a lot of people
by not declaring any kind of victory in
Ukraine and not moving Russia to a war
footing with a full military
mobilization what's your read on that
that's a good observation I mean there
were several things that were missing
from what so many people had expected to
hear or see today first of all there was
I mean there was no oomph I mean it was
a lack of enthusiasm it was you know
there was stuff there but it it didn't
have the feel of a nation that is
winning in a major conflict uh with such
high stakes as the president described
him and it also didn't have the feel
that you know they were getting ready to
really launch into something I didn't
you didn't feel any momentum coming out
of it it was smaller frankly than usual
not as much Hardware the flyover was
supposedly canceled because of weather I
would I would defer to them but we'll
see
um no Declaration of Victory no uh
declaration of war no escalation and not
even a uh they called to mobilize a
general mobilization so so no Call to
Arms if you will the whole Focus was on
connecting Russian people
trying to legitimize what they're doing
in Ukraine by connecting it to what
happened in 1945 and I think it was uh
not that big a deal
we know that Western intelligence
sources were briefing that Mr Putin had
told his generals to produce a victory
for him by today by May 9th is the lack
of a victory claim is it a sign that the
Russian military is failing or have
Western intelligence agencies been
somewhat Off the Mark here
no actually I would say that our
intelligence
um has been uh very good going back to
before 24 February
um remarkably accurate and and I also
liked the way that we have shared it
publicly on certain things which really
got the Kremlin on the back foot uh that
was important I think the the problem
for the Russians is that they have no
Victory to celebrate I mean every single
thing that they have tried to do has
generally failed uh even mariopal which
should have been gone in the first week
you still have these incredibly tough uh
Ukrainian troops
that are still holding out and uh I
think these guys are going to be
compared to the 300 Spartans for a long
time and so there's there was not
something that the Russians could really
um put a flag in
and you know we we seem here in the west
to have been surprised by the the lack
of the Russian military's ability to to
move quickly when The Invasion began
they couldn't take Kiev now there are
reports coming out that inside Russia
that the military is having trouble
convincing particularly young men to
enlist how serious of a threat to I
guess the viability of the Russian
military do you see that being
yeah they that's a great point they have
a serious Manpower problem first of all
the population of Russia about 140
million so not a large population for
such a huge country they have generally
avoided uh conscripting any soldiers
from Moscow or St Petersburg so the two
main population centers actually are not
proportionally represented in the armed
forces in in the ranks
um there are reports that not only are
soldiers who are deployed are beginning
to disobey orders or refusing orders but
also people
even traditionally do not show up 100
for conscription date and I think this
is part of the reason why we did not see
um a call for General mobilization
because it would be humiliating to have
large percentages of Russians uh who
supposedly are so supportive of what the
Kremlin is doing to not report
for uh mobilization instead with the
office that runs mobilization for the
Russian Minister of Defense sent out an
invite would anybody like to to do this
so they're they're having some serious
Manpower problems and I really have to
say
I'm surprised that Minister shoigu still
has his job and his head and he's been
the Minister of Defense now for almost
eight years so he he sort of presides
over this whole thing and um
you're surprised though what do you
think it means I mean we we've we've
seen some public you know dress Downing
of intelligence officials in Russia but
I mean Vladimir Putin he needs the
generals he needs the military on his
side he's he knows that's that's the
nature of an authoritarian state so I
mean how stable is everything inside
when you consider that you know no heads
have been rolling
yeah that's that good point
um sugars there but I didn't see General
garissimov today
um he clearly General garasimov the
chief of the general staff
would typically have been there featured
prominently camera had a role instead
sure who is the defense minister played
the the senior military commander kind
of roll today now I don't know I've I've
been looking at speculation all day
about why garasimov was not there some
people think he was wounded in an attack
uh several days ago when he was visiting
at one of the headquarters some people
think he's you know maybe he's really
busy and then some have speculated that
maybe he's been
pushed aside I didn't see lavarov either
foreign minister lavrov
um was not featured in any of the of the
things so
um maybe shoigu is still there because
he got rid of aggressive I don't know I
shouldn't even speculate but this is
something that we all always did in the
Cold War was watch who's up there on the
of the public Bureau you know who's
standing next to the Secretary General
of the Communist party on these big
events who's standing close so
um that's what I was doing today was
trying to figure out who was there and
who wasn't yeah I mean it's like ghosts
of the Soviet Union on display on Red
Square again today General Ben Hodges
says always General we appreciate your
time and your valuable insights tonight
thank you
thanks for the privilege